take an adjective such as implacable or
a verb like proliferate or even another
noun crony and add a suffix such as ity
or tion or is M you've created a new
noun implacability proliferation
cronyism sounds impressive right wrong
you've just unleashed a flesh-eating
zombie nouns made from the other parts
of speech are called nominalizations
academics love them so do lawyers
bureaucrats business writers I call them
zombie ends because they consume the
living they cannibalize active verbs
they suck the lifeblood from adjectives
and they substitute abstract entities
for human beings here's an example the
proliferation of nominalizations in a
discursive formation may be an
indication of a tendency toward
pomposity and abstraction huh this
sentence contains no fewer than seven
nominalizations it fails to tell us who
is doing what when we eliminate or
reanimate most of the zombie nouns so
tendency becomes tend abstraction
becomes abstract then we add a human
subject and some active verbs the
sentence springs back to life writers
who overload their sentences with
nominalizations tend to sound pompous
and abstract only one zombie noun the
keyword nominalizations has been allowed
to remain standing
at their best nominalizations help us
express complex ideas perception
intelligence epistemology at their worst
they impede clear communication to get a
feeling for how zombie gangs work
release a few of them into a lively
sentence and watch them SAP all its
energy George Orwell played this game in
his essay politics in the English
language he started with a well-known
verse from the book of Ecclesiastes in
the Bible it says I returned and saw
Under the Sun that the race is not to
the Swift nor the battle to the strong
neither yet bread to the wise nor yet
riches to men of understanding nor yet
favour to men of skill but time and
chance happeneth to them all now here's
Orwell's modern English version
objective considerations of contemporary
phenomena compel the conclusion that
success or failure in competitive
activities exhibits no tendency to be
commensurate with innate capacity but
that a considerable element of the
unpredictable must invariably be taken
into account the bible passage speaks to
our senses and emotions with concrete
nouns descriptions of people and punchy
abstract nouns such as race battle
riches time chance not a zombie among
them Orwell's satirical translation on
the other hand is teeming with
nominalizations and other vague
abstractions the zombies have taken over
and the humans have fled the village
zombie nouns do their worst damage when
they gather in jargon generating packs
and swallow every noun verb and
adjective in sight so globe becomes
global becomes globalised becomes
globalization the grandfather of all
nominalizations
antidisestablishmentarianism contains at
least two verbs three adjectives and six
other nouns inside it's distended belly
a paragraph heavily populated by
nominalizations will send your readers
straight to sleep
rescue them from the zombie apocalypse
with vigorous verb driven sentences that
are concrete and clearly structured you
want your sentences to live not to join
the Living Dead
you